and welcome back to CBS this morning we
start with this this hour two more
charter jets landed in the US over night
carrying Americans evacuated from
overseas in the midst of the corona
virus outbreak more than 300 passengers
were aboard those flights one landed at
Travis Air Force Base in California the
other at Lackland Air Force Base in
Texas the Americans had been quarantined
aboard the diamond Princess cruise ship
in Japan that ship alone has seen more
than 450 cases of the illness including
about 40 Americans Deborah pata is in
Yokohama Japan where the ship is still
docked Deborah we're hearing some of the
Americans who were evacuated are
confirmed to have the virus good morning
yes that's right US officials say only
after passengers had been evacuated did
they learn that 14 of them had tested
positive for the corona virus now we're
told that those Americans were quickly
moved to a specialized area of the
planes and held in isolation for the
remainder of the flights we've also
learned that when they were taken off
the ship the patients were not
displaying symptoms before boarding the
planes that's significant because
yesterday on Face the Nation the head of
the National Institute of Allergy and
Infectious Diseases
told CBS News cruise ship passengers
showing symptoms would not be cleared to
be flown out and the more than 40
Americans already diagnosed on the ship
have to stay in hospitals in Japan and
cannot return home the latest group of
evacuees will be held in quarantine and
their respective locations for an
additional 14 days meanwhile officials
overseas are working to track down over
2,000 passengers the disembarked the
Wester dam cruise ship in Cambodia they
were deemed to be virus free but now an
American woman has tested positive for
the virus
Tony Debora patta for us in Japan
Deborah thank you very much